- Hey guys, this is
Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Welcome back to my channel.
I'm just back from a nice long run
that I did with my wife,
we are preparing for our
next marathon, this July.
And now we are ready
to get some nice food.
So I'm gonna eat that before I do
the actual video for today,
but just as a spoiler, it's
going to be about visibility.
It's going to be about what you
need to do in your workplace
to actually stand out and be
perceived by the senior leaders
and thought leaders in your organization,
as actually somebody who really adds value
to your team and your organization.
Visibility is a key concept that you need
to understand in order to advance
in any corporate organization of any kind.
So hang in here with me,
it's going to be interesting
it's going to be very important.
So once again welcome
to another coffee break
with Firm Learning, my name is Heinrich,
and today we talk about visibility.
Visibility is really a game changer.
Visibility can make or break your career.
So it's super crucial and important
that you understand what
visibility is all about.
And the reason why I chose this topic
for this video is the following,
I recently thought back
about a conversation I had
with some colleagues
at an internship I did
at a tech consulting
company, many many years ago.
I was still in university,
still in my undergrad.
And I was working at a large
German DAX Corporation,
it's the big blue chip
stock index in Germany.
And this consulting firm was
working for this large company,
so we were on the client
side almost every day.
So I noticed that in a
period of a couple of weeks
all of the colleagues were
getting a bit more nervous,
there were some kind of
a tension in the room
that I didn't observe in the
earlier weeks of my internship.
So I asked a bit around, what is going on?
And I learned that actually
now it was designation season,
so they had a process where
two or three times a year,
each colleague got evaluated
and if they matched certain criteria,
both regarding tenure but
also regarding performance,
they would be designated
to the next level.
And then of course would
get a higher salary,
more benefits, and so on.
And this was obviously a big thing
for everybody in the company.
So everybody was a bit nervous, of course,
trying to make the very best impression
at work at this time.
Trying to perform as good as they could.
And then I overheard a conversation
that two of the more senior
colleagues on the team had,
which really made me think.
And this conversation they
had was about visibility.
And what do I mean by that, what happened?
Well, they were talking
about another client
on the team who is a bit more junior,
and they were discussing
him, and they were saying
"Hey, this guy, he is a good
guy, he's doing good work,
"but he's just not visible enough."
This is what they were saying.
So they were doubting
if he would make the cut
and actually get the promotion.
And for me this for
something completely new.
Of course I was very young,
and maybe also a bit naive,
and the way I was thinking about the work
was that well, if you do a good job,
at some point this is
going to be recognized,
and then at some point your
team lead, or your supervisor,
would pick you and then you designate you.
And then this is how you
advance in your career.
Do the job as good as you
can, and this would be enough.
But the reality is it's not
always working like that.
This is far too simplistic
to really describe
how these kind of things work, and happen,
in especially larger corporations.
But I trust this is not very different
in most smaller sized
corporations as well.
And yes of course, doing a good job,
having a good and stellar performance
at the things that you do,
is of course important,
and will make a difference
in one way or the other
how far you get in your career.
I think it doesn't
matter how much politics
are going on in a company, in the end,
how good you do your job will always
somehow influence your chances
in terms of getting along,
and doing then the next
step in your career.
But, and I think this
is a very basic truth,
that it's probably hard to understand
for many new joiners, people
just starting out in business,
it is not enough.
Other concepts, for instance visibility,
is very, very important.
And let me give you an example
of how that could play out,
why that might be important.
So if you think about how these
designation processes work
in all companies, and of
course here are differences
from company here to company.
But in general this works is that
once or twice every year,
the HR community will meet
with the business leaders
of the organization,
and they will ask themselves the question,
okay, whom can I designate
to the next level?
Who makes the cut to now
advance to the next position?
And yes, of course, this
is probably more like this
in roles like consulting or banking,
where you have this cycle of
constantly being designated
every couple of years
if you're good enough.
Maybe this is slightly
different in an industry
where it's more opportunity based,
if there's now a role that is opening up,
but then people ask themselves,
okay, who can we put in this role?
But there as well you will
have the evaluation cycles
like this, that also work
somehow in this manner.
So the HR leaders work together
with the business leaders,
they're having a discussion,
and they ask themselves,
okay, who am I going to designate?
And usually how this works
if somebody prepares a case
for the individual who
then gets this cast,
and kind of makes the case if he proposes
to designate the person, or not,
and what the reasons
are, whether this person
is worthwhile to get designated.
And now think about the
role of this person.
Usually it's a senior
leader in the organization,
he will have several more junior
colleagues working for him,
maybe not all of them are
directly working for himself,
so he needs to reach out
to maybe an in between boss
who then has more direct
exposure to the person,
in order to understand if
this guy is a good guy or not.
If this guy is worth getting designated.
So often, in this kinds of situations,
the person actually makes
kind of a significant part
of the decision, namely by
making the recommendation
whether to designate the person or not,
is not even doing that based
on first-hand experience
working with the candidate,
but rather only maybe
drawing from hearsay.
Drawing from conversations
he had with other people
where actually you give a
more or less favorable review
of the individual or not.
So what is actually visibility?
Visibility is how visible
you are, as the name says,
to the senior leaders in organization.
Do they know that you exist?
Does somebody maybe two
levels above your boss
know that you exist?
Does he know where your strengths are?
Does he really know what you
did for the organization,
what the projects were
that you were working on?
How are you did in these projects?
What other initiatives might
be that you were driving?
And really how important you are
to the organization as a whole?
Is this visible to the
people to whom this matters,
namely the senior leaders in
the firm you're working in?
So now put yourself in
the shoes of a person
who needs to do these
kinds of review processes,
maybe he knows you a
little bit, maybe not,
but it becomes obvious
that how visible you are
to this person is super
crucial, and super important,
in the specific decision he needs to make
about what your future
is in the organization.
And whether this needs a designation,
or any kind of other review process,
or other just perception that
the person has about you,
doesn't matter.
But how visible you are to the person
clearly makes a huge difference
for you and your career.
And while doing a good job
might be helpful for that,
might be a necessary condition for that,
it's not the only thing.
And this alone, for sure,
will not make you visible
to a person several steps up in the ladder
above your team lead, for instance,
because he just might see the
performance of the team lead,
and the team as a whole, and notice
actually it's going quite well.
But it's very hard for him to judge,
just by looking at it outside in,
what the contribution of
individual team members
in the team might be,
that he then might also need to review.
So is this a bit unfair?
Yes it is, for sure it's unfair.
In a perfect world the only thing
that should matter is
how good you do your job.
How reliable you are,
how well you deliver on the
things you're supposed to do,
this should be all that's relevant
when these things are decided.
But the truth is it's
just not how this works.
This is just not the truth,
just doing a good job alone won't do it.
In one sentence that is often described
in order to really make this
graspable is the sentence
perception is reality.
Perception is reality.
Think about that, what
really is the reality?
At least in such a business context,
is not so much what you really do.
I mean you can sit at home
and then talk to your partner
all the things that you did,
and how great of a job you did,
and how important you
are for the corporation,
but if the perception
of everybody around you
is that that actually you're
not really doing a good job,
and you're not really adding
value to the business,
then this won't help you at all.
Perception is reality.
What you need to be good at,
and what you need to become good at,
is the management of the perceptions
of the people around you.
And yes, for sure, this is politics.
This is what is going on in
these large corporations.
And this is also what makes
these places kind of annoying,
or maybe tiresome to work in,
because they are full
of politics like this.
But the truth is also that
it's not necessarily better
in smaller organizations.
In shades of gray, for sure,
but things like that happen everywhere.
And if you want to be
successful in your job,
and I would say not only in your job
but almost everything you do in life,
in the end what matters is
understanding this principal
of perception is reality.
Do a good job, this is the reality,
but make sure the other
people have the perception
that you are actually doing a good job.
Because if other people
do not perceive that,
do not have the perception
that you are doing a good job,
then actually doing a good
job is no help for you at all.
Especially in the context
where you're an employee
and do not directly benefit
from the results of your work.
So now I'd like to give
you three tangible tips.
What you can do, especially
if you are a new joiner,
if you are in a position
that you just started
your work life,
what you can do to actually
improve your visibility.
So guys, if you're getting
value so far from this video,
please press the like button,
and please also subscribe to the channel
here on the subscribe button below,
in case you are not subscribed yet.
This would mean a lot to me,
I have many more content planned
for the next days and weeks.
Are you ready?
Three tips.
Number one, first clearly
communicate your successes.
And very often we have this mentality
of maybe we are a bit shy,
we do not want to speak out
about what we actually
accomplished at work.
What we actually did in
the last days or weeks,
because we feel like
we do not want to brag
about our achievements,
especially not towards your boss.
Where you may be even afraid
that this is perceived
as arrogant, or something like that.
And while this is very understandable,
and for sure you need to be a
bit careful to not overdo it,
it's important that you
let other people know
if you did something great
that is really adding value
to the business or to your team.
Do good things, and to talk about that.
And this is an important principle.
Don't just do good things
and then not talk about that,
but do good things and then
do also talk about that
to your colleagues, to your boss.
Not in a pretentious manner,
but rather just letting
them know what you did
in your next team meeting,
in your next one on one with the chief,
just recap with them the deliverables
that you accomplished in the last days.
And just make sure that
it's really clear to them
what you actually achieved,
what you got done in the last days,
don't just keep this to yourself
and just assume that
maybe over some other ways
they will know and understand
what the good things
and the skills are that you have.
But aggressively let them know
about the good things that you do.
Because if you do not
advocate these things,
who else supposed to do that?
Maybe your colleagues say "Yes,
"this guy he was really helpful,
"and he helped me a lot in my work."
But I mean come on, you
cannot really rely on that.
And again, perception is reality.
It's not enough that you just do it,
but you need to make sure that
there's also the perception
on the other side of the table
that you actually got these things done.
Because only then, this is
really adding value for you
in your career if you just do this.
The second tip is related to that,
and it's about how you
communicate your achievements
to your team colleagues, but
also to your supervisors.
And there's a pretty
natural tendency, I'd say,
that if you work in a team
you always talk about we.
We did this, we achieved this last week,
we worked on that, we got that
done, and so on and so forth.
And while this is of course often fair,
while you often just want to make sure
that it will not take the compliments
for something that maybe not
you, but your team achieved,
very often this leads to the perception
that actually your specific contribution
wasn't that large, but it
was rather a team effort.
Everybody did something,
and yes of course you also did something,
but it was an effort of the team.
And I think what's important
here is to always also stress
what your specific contribution
to that result was.
So yes, we can talk about
what you achieved as a team,
but then also say "I did
this, I worked on that.
"Due to my efforts last week,
"because I called somebody up last week,
"this is then what happened."
And this is not about
you making something up.
This is not about something
else, or somebody else did it,
and then you just claimed that you did it.
This is of course not at all
what I'm recommending you to do.
But the many things that you did do,
the many things where you
really did take ownership,
and did make an effort to really bring
that success to the
team, make it transparent
that this actually was your contribution,
that you actually did that.
And I think this is an insider
tip that not only applies
to how you communicate,
but also in for instance
written applications,
or even job interviews,
if you're now supposed to describe
what you achieved in the past,
here again it's very
common for people to say
"We did this, we did that," and so on.
And then for you as an intern,
if you try to put yourself in
the shoes of the other guy,
it's really hard to understand,
okay, but this guy, Heinrich,
what did he really achieve?
What can he do for us?
So also always stress not
only what the team result was,
but what your specific contribution
to that result has been.
Just to make that visible and
also create the impression
that you as a person really
add value to the team.
My third tip is to pick up initiative,
and organize some things beyond
your daily, day-to-day job.
And what do I mean by that?
Often in a team or in an organization
there are things where you can volunteer,
or where you can take the
lead and do something,
which might not directly
be expected from you.
Or it might not be that
your team comes to you
and tells you "Heinrich,
this what I want you to do."
But still it just adds value to the team,
and if only to the spirit,
and to kind of the team
feeling as a whole.
And some examples here could be
that you for instance
organize a team event.
You just organize an event for your team,
where then you organization everything,
and then the team goes maybe
to an offsite in the evening,
or somewhere else, just
to have a good time.
And then hopefully everybody
comes back in the office
the next day and it
feels like a more bonded,
a better team to everybody.
This could be one example.
Or maybe you organize
some kind of sports event
in your office, or you take ownership
of any kind of other
initiative that is going on.
So these are little things where
this is likely going beyond your job,
this is not directly expected from you,
but you show ownership,
you show initiative,
you show that you want to contribute
beyond what is necessarily
directly expected from you.
And by that this will be visible.
If now you have a team
lead and now he will see
that the team is gone to a team event,
with or without him,
he will very quickly pick up
who that was who organized that
and who made this effort for better
team experience for everybody.
And of course, your main roads,
your main responsibilities
will always be more important.
Don't do these things
they put you in danger
of actually delivering against the things
that you're really supposed to do,
or that are really expected from you.
Because if you do that then
it doesn't really matter
if you organized the great team event,
if your actual job is not done right.
So prioritize correctly, but very often
you will find yourself
having a bit of spare time,
having a bit of extra capacity
that you could invest in
these kinds of things,
and then it is super
valuable if you do that.
If you take initiative, take leadership.
And then do something
good for the organization,
this will be recognized.
And this for sure will put you on the list
of these more seniors leaders,
and then make you more visible to them.
So let's recap, visibility
is super important,
and it means how visible you
are to the senior leaders
in your organization.
Do they know that you exist?
Do they know what you
are doing for the team?
Do they know why you really add value
to their organization as a whole?
Perception is reality.
It doesn't matter,
it's not enough if you do just a good job,
you need to make sure that
other people understand
and perceive that you do a good job.
Otherwise it's just not worth a lot.
So make sure that this
perception is there.
Make sure that you are visible.
I hope that if you follow these tips,
that this will help you.
And if you really enjoyed this
please click the like button
and subscribe to this channel below.
This would really mean a lot to me
if you just subscribed to my channel,
I have many more content
pieces lined up for
in the next days or weeks.
So I would love to keep
you here on the channel.
Thank you, this is Heinrich
from Firm Learning.